I think she's lying I don't think she
was actually told yeah we're paying you
less because you're a woman also do you
do the same jobs or is it just that
you're less entertaining I mean that's
what you find a point on this I didn't
scrimmage the Women's World Cup soccer
team the gold medal winning Women's
World Cup soccer team whilst to the
under 15 football club from Dallas
-fort ladies that is so embarrassing
that is so embarrassing that's like the
most embarrassing thing I've ever heard
in my life
what up guys welcome to the just curly
things YouTube channel and welcome to my
reaction series today I have a special
guest on the channel the newest member
of the audacity Network welcome to the
show Christine hello
um she's got very fun videos on her
Channel essay videos talking about
today's craziness tell them a little bit
about it
um the state of the world especially the
last three years drove me a bit insane
so I wanted to share with the world my
journey into the insanity to try and see
if we can find any kind of sense in it
and which has proven very hard yeah yeah
she did have my video on my on my
channel a couple weeks ago you guys
loved it it was a lot of a lot of
positive remarks
um so guys make sure you like the video
that's the most important metric that
YouTube uses subscribe to our channel so
today we are reacting to Ben Shapiro are
you Ben fan I am I'm a big bench hero
fan I put him as my top five
conservatives of all time on Twitter
people got so mad why I I guess they
don't they don't like some of his
foreign policy stuff okay but I just
come to see him dunk on these feminists
you know what I mean it's like I'm like
you can't you can't minimize this guy's
impact just because you don't think we
should like be sending money to Israel
or whatever like they got some I just
look I I love watching him dunk on these
girls so I would pay you remember when
he would go to colleges and just dunk on
chick chick chick chick bet a man yeah I
mean I I think he's very very good at
articulating his points and he can do it
in such a
such a detailed way he can like make one
point and then go into all these sub
points and he just gets it on point
pretty much every time he's so smart and
I'm like
I would just pay I wish he would go back
to the colleges like I know he's kind of
involved in his content where he does
more commentary now but I really miss
the college days where he would just
dunk
um but today we're reacting to him I
think he's arguing with someone about
the pay Gap why don't we pull up the
clip when Joe Biden is not incoherently
babbling about illegal immigration he's
incoherently babbling about
the supposed pay Gap now the pay Gap is
one of the most overwrought ridiculous
things in American public life the
notion that women are being paid less
for the same exact work is not backed by
statistical evidence the reality is that
the pay Gap is almost entirely a
creation of differentials in work hours
in jobs chosen it is a differential in
time taken off from the workforce women
tend to take more time out of the
workforce because they want to be home
with the kids in many cases the basic
idea that a woman Works an hour a man
Works in our exact same job exact same
credentials since the woman gets paid
less is just silly it it actually is not
true it's been widely debunked Christina
how Summers has done that work many many
times before in fact in America's
largest cities it's been true for years
that people who are fresh out of college
without having taken time out of the
workforce women in the same Industries
tend to be paid as highly or more than
men that's according to Time magazine
that goes back a full decade doesn't
matter we're still going to keep
promoting the quote-unquote equity-based
idea that if women on average are paid
less than men are all of those
extraneous factors for all those
confounds well you know that's still not
good enough we have to equalize pay
between men and women and pretend that
women are not getting paid enough for
the same exact work as a man so Biden's
Administration earlier this week tried
out Megan Rapinoe who's the least
victimized victim in American public
life Megan Rapinoe is an extraordinarily
famous gay woman who has not so far as
I'm aware uh been victimized in any of
her media coverage she grew up extremely
privileged she she did not grow up
impoverished
she has faced from what I can see very
little in the way of actual life
obstacles to success she is now treated
as a paragon of feminist virtue even
though the claims that she makes are
overtly false repeatedly like this one
there was Megan Rapido complaining she's
not paid the same as the men yeah you're
not paid the same as the men lady
because you're in women's soccer which
makes money once every four years or as
men soccer makes money pretty much all
the time and the men's World Cup is a
multiple like a large multiple bigger
than the Women's World Cup and you guys
signed a contract so if you don't like
your contract you could have not signed
that contract
but here's Megan Rapinoe complaining
that she does the same work as a man and
doesn't get paid the same as a man
four World Cup championships and four
Olympic gold medals for the United
States
and despite those wins I've been
devalued I've been disrespected and
dismissed because I am a woman
and I've been told that I don't deserve
any more than less because I am a woman
you see despite all the wins I'm still
paid less than men who do the same job
that I do they don't do the same job
that you do oh my gosh if you're looking
she was actually told that I think she's
lying I don't think she was actually
told yeah we're paying you less because
you're a woman also do you do the same
jobs or is it just that you're less
entertaining people don't want to watch
and it's a sad reality for us female
athletes to be honest I I loved sports
but like there's no cash payout at the
end of it and you're really lucky like
honestly we're lucky to even have a
league because the men pay for the
league so if any like none of the the
women's sports leagues really make money
yeah I mean you could maybe look at an
exception here or there but not really
across the board they all lose money I
did college sports they make zero
dollars zero it's it we negative money
and instead of saying thank you for
allowing us to compete yeah they
they whine they moan and it's just like
why don't you say thank you they say why
don't why aren't I equal because I am
the oppressed woman it's like shut up at
least you like you're able to do it you
know like if you're saying that there's
they opened up all of these women's
leagues and yet these leagues aren't
making any money thinking you know
strategically and like a business
you should really shut down those
businesses because they're failing so
the fact that they're still remaining
open whilst being funded by men
um surely shows the kind of the goodness
at least in in men's hearts that they're
still willing to fund something that
isn't making them any money just so
women can do something they enjoy men
are benevolent they're very benevolent
towards women that's why women when you
think about it us voting we have more
power than men because not only do we
have our own voting power we're not
benevolent towards men but men are
benevolent towards women so we have the
power of like getting like using our
Beauty to get resources from them and
the power of voting take it away repeal
the 19th I don't know what what
amendment you guys got here but in
America they don't you know how I know
because Megan rappino anytime you want
you can go play I'm a men's team you can
try
you can try
after all gender is a so it's a social
construct we've been informed by the
left that gender does not exist it's
completely a social construct so since
gender is a social construct anytime
Megan rappana wants she can go try and
play with the men
that is not gonna go great for making it
happen if she is not doing the same work
that a man is doing this is like saying
that a woman lifting weights like her
job is to lift weights she's doing
exactly the same job as a man when she
wins a gold medal in a weightlifting
competition well not really considering
the man is probably listening twice
lifting twice as much weight as the
woman
I mean that's what you find a point on
this but in a scrimmage the Women's
World Cup soccer team the gold medal
winning Women's World Cup soccer team
lost to the under 15 football club from
Dallas
boys ladies that is so embarrassing that
is so embarrassing
that's like the most embarrassing thing
I've ever heard in my life please like
just stick stick to play into with women
like stop trying to be men like just
take the owl because we don't need to
take these L's public like we don't need
to play these games you know I used to
play basketball with dudes all the time
I have absolutely beat men in basketball
but they're probably taking it easy on
me let's just be honest here let's just
call them I used to get mad at my dad
and my cousins who are men when I was
growing up whenever I would play like
football with them or suckers
be like no like you've got to go easy
it's not fair I'm a girl yeah no because
you you'd be trying to win and you're
like I can I literally don't stand the
time no zero chance ball Club from
Dallas the under 15s a bunch of 14 year
old like yes it was a scrimmage but also
like you lost a bunch of 14 year old
boys no it's not no actually you're not
doing the same work as the men
it's a this is all absurd okay it's just
absurd and her proclaiming she's
speaking from the podium of the Damned
White House she's been on every major
television show complaining about her
fate she signed voluntarily a contract
as to her pay and the Women's World Cup
again is a fraction the size of the
men's World Cup
it's amazing but don't worry Joe Biden
assures us that there's not a single
thing a man can do a woman can't do
better not a single thing you know it's
funny that they take a pay cut the men
so like the women get a third of the
prize money even though the World Cup
brought in I think seven billion dollars
for the men and less than a billion for
the women and they're crazy and they get
a third of the prize money it's like
women just want special treatment
special it doesn't make any sense and
it's so funny because they marketed as
like women are fighting for our rights
even the old women like I I covered this
yesterday but them the women running in
the marathon they were they would say oh
it's the woman like because there was
this chick she ran the first marathon
and the men were like pulling her out of
the race and they're like she overcame
but they're pulling her out of the race
because she was a man's race she wasn't
supposed to be there like do you know
what I mean like like
you know it was like it was like a race
you had to qualify for and all the
reporters had to like wait for her to
finish oh you know what I mean like she
was last and they were like oh this is a
victory like oh and you know I mean
running a marathon's heart I ran one and
she ran it faster than I did I'll give
her that I'm a slow person but it's like
but it's like okay she didn't overcome a
barrier but it's so funny because they
like rewrite the history by making this
like barriers they've overcome yeah when
they're just like give me it's like why
didn't you start your own race Diane you
know what I mean it's like always men
can't pee their name in the snow better
man can't open pickle jars better men
can't pick up heavyweights better men
that is a baseball okay personal
experience when I first left home I was
making
nachos so like I got my Doritos cheese
on it and then it got to the dip and my
first breakdown was over the fact that
my dad wasn't there to open the salsa
for me and I was so angry I literally
wanted to smash the jar open and I was
like reading all these tricks get a tea
towel every chick has had that moment
when you're like God mine's with my car
like every time I would drive my car I
don't have a car now because I live in
ingwood but when I was in the US I had a
car and every time I would drive at home
my dad would be like your oil you're
there and I'm like I'm sorry Dad you
really just give me the car I'm like I'm
sorry but I don't we're on average nope
it turns out every single thing a man
can do a woman can do just as well or
better which is why he should probably
resign and let Kamala Harris be
president
I've told my daughters granddaughters
from the time they would all not to
understand what I was saying
and I mean it
there's not a single thing a man can do
that a woman can't do as well or better
not a single thing it's so funny because
when you're younger you kind of believe
what they're saying with the older you
get you're just like wow they are big
Liars oh it's kind of isn't it kind of
true when you're younger because before
puberty girls and boys are fairly
similar in in size and scale I know that
boys have bigger hearts and lungs but
generally when you are kids everything
is even when you play like football when
you're really young like five years old
it feels pretty yeah but then they hit
puberty it's like oh yeah
but even like when they're young like
they're still interested in different
things if you look at like I disagree
even like even when kids are young
um
so you see this is this is how far the
programmer has gone for for you to even
still think that
before puberty boys and girls are equal
I don't think it's true because
even like hand-eye coordination like
there are so many things that women just
don't have as um have it down naturally
as men if you look at the female bone
structure your hips tend to dip like so
from your hips to your knees there's
like a dip and Men usually have
straighter legs in that region that
alone makes a man able to jump higher
run faster than women and that is from
birth that's that doesn't happen during
puberty that's like your bone structure
so I just think like the differences are
always the puberty just accelerates and
right
I am larger that's what happens yeah
yeah single thing anything
really there are things that women can
do better than men there are things men
can do better than what name them no
because seriously Ben I've been
literally trying to think of anything
for months nothing but frankly I'm
shocking he still thinks the distinction
exists he can't even I would love to ask
I would love to have this conflict Ben I
can't think of anything I swear I
thought it was nurturing until I saw
that we kill the elderly and the babies
more I'm like well that really stumped
me on this I I
I have been thinking about this for
months I'm like men just must be
superior beings except a karaoke King
to find what a woman is it turns out
that many men are better at being women
than women according to Joe Biden that's
true have you been following the March
Madness NCAA tournament I mean you'd
have to have been living on the moon not
to because it really is exciting stuff
and here is the thing everybody
everybody puts a little bit of money
White House released this asinine
asinine Instagram picture the other day
that it's equal payday did you know
white men make the whole dollar Asian
women make 87 cents white women make 79
cents black women make 63 cents American
Indian okay I just had a thought this
might be a cancelable thought but if
white men make the most money and black
women make 63 cents right in a way
haven't white men paid reparations
through the tax system because they're
paying the majority of the taxes stuff
like women I just I want to know where
these numbers have come from because uh
you know if you look at in America I
don't know the exact stats but the
majority of people in America are white
and of minorities so if you look at it
that way then obviously the numbers are
going to be seeming I don't know I just
think this sends them a message like
like this is just this is the vision in
itself they're trying to they're trying
to talk and they don't talk about why
they make more money too like different
Industries like different groups are
interested in different Industries right
so certain industries make more money
than others yeah they don't talk about
like why they make more money and you're
right they are the majority yeah so it's
like
yeah I don't how can native women make
60 cents Hispanic or Latino women make
55 cents okay so I have some questions I
have some some major questions first of
all
right you're taking into account no
confounds right number of hours in the
workforce amount of time taken out of
the workforce what kind of job you have
and none of that is taken into account
second you notice that it starts with a
white men make the whole dollar how
about Asian men how do they do in the
United States how about like
nigerian-born American immigrants
they do really really well in the United
States as it turns out so why are white
men at the top oh because white men are
always evil that's why when you just put
white men at the top that means
everything that follows that message is
so infiltrated over here and I can say
that from experience I
wasn't really aware of everything that
is to do with your Channel all of the
people at Daily wire like wasn't aware
of it until I went to college which is
when we're like 16 to 18 here
um and I did media a level and in my
media a level almost every lesson
without fail the analysis of any piece
of media we would look at my teacher who
was Canadian would tell me
ask the class okay and what's the reason
for this and it was like almost
collectively everyone would say straight
white men middle-aged straight white men
and I I actually got kicked out of that
classroom for for saying that not all
straight white men are bad because I
actually found it quite rude because I'm
like hang on a minute my dad is a
straight middle white man my dad is
bloody lovely what do you mean he's this
awful no I had the same thing because
I'm like I'm like my dad's very nice and
especially because they would do like
all the rich white man I'm like well my
dad does pretty well you know and they
always say rich white men and I'm like
my my dad isn't even Rich what do you
well and I'm like okay and they they
don't even want to do like that like my
dad used to work 80 90 hour a week so
you guys want to do so why why is he
Rich well like because he's hard working
I'm like
but and the other thing they don't talk
about is like like I don't understand
how they can demonize a whole gender
like ah men it's like Ugh women
so I'm gonna start saying every time I
hear that actually I do do that
sometimes
sorry guys America is
also are we to believe I mean according
to the left this this violates the
intersectional hierarchy the only reason
for this would be discrimination of
course right intersectional concerns
your membership and various identity
groups that decides just how bad America
is to you so according I I think it's it
will make more sense to generalize women
than to generalize men because men are
way more disagreeable men usually tend
to
fight over silly things with each other
women even though they do fight with job
but women tend to want to be in groups
so it it makes more sense to what to
generalize women than to generalize men
and who is it like the um people from
like fresh effect like Myron and like
sneaker they all say like typically like
most girls you meet are kind of a copy
and paste of each other like they're all
they all wear into their Instagrams
astrology so like yeah it does kind of
make sense to generalize women more we
tend to group more together our women
typically tend towards the whole Equity
thing whereas men even though we group
together we we place ourselves in
hierarchy hierarchies to this chart
the one that the White House just put
out
in order of people who are discriminated
against
it goes like least discriminated against
Asian-American women then white women
apparently white women are more
discriminated against than Asian
American women kind of incredible
wouldn't have predicted that also it
turns out that black women are why where
is the ginger discrimination I couldn't
change her my whole life I'm a minority
like I never get put in the minority box
I am the I am in the smallest minority
on the planet that is the most rare I'm
in the second most rare combination red
hair and blue eyes is the most rare I
have green same yeah yes yeah where is
my where is my that combo is is rare
where's my my minority gingers do you
have a really hard time like especially
growing up over here if you grow up
Ginger you had it roughly we were so in
sperm banks they've stopped taking like
ginger sperm
and that's probably oh that's not
discrimination at all
give me my my my money please less
discriminated against and Hispanic or
Latino women because black women make 63
cents well Hispanic or Latino women make
55 cents so apparently America is super
duper racist against Hispanic and Latino
women but only like a little bit less
racist against black women okay all of
this is just crap it's just crap it does
not bear statistical relation to reality
men have different jobs than women men
tend to go into stem Fields women tend
not to go into stem fields that is not
due to systemic discrimination all of
the big tech companies have been trying
to recruit women into these fields for a
very long time Lauren Summers the former
treasury secretary under Bill Clinton
got himself in hot water by pointing out
and it's so funny when the robber meets
the pavement they just fire all these
chicks that's why I don't think that's
why I think they're overpaid because I
look at the before and after at these
tech companies they're like all these
diversity hires gotta go and you used to
see like those women that would be like
this is what I do in a day at Google and
I was like I have my meeting in my latte
and then I like took an hour lunch and
then I like where the men were like do
it you know they're like too busy to
doing to go on Tick Tock you know
I'm like well here we go we have
different preferences in job selection
than men do this happens to be accurate
he also pointed out that if you look at
test performance when it comes to math
and science what you tend to see is that
the averages for men and women tend to
be pretty similar but that at the tail
end of the spectrum the curves are
different that male curve in terms of
test scores on math and science tends to
show a lot of really dumb men and a lot
of really smart men and the average
somewhere in the middle and for women a
lot of people in the middle very few
very dumb and very few very great at
Science and Tech
hey that does not mean that if you just
pick a woman that she's going to be
worse off than a man it means that when
you're looking at a statistical average
of wages you have to look at factors
like this
again women tend to enter the stem
Fields less often than men
and actually when you look at countries
that have supposedly more gender
equality what you see is that women
enter stem Fields there even less often
than in countries where there is more
gender inequality why because if a woman
has to get a high earning job in order
to support her family it turns out that
she will pick a stem field because
that's where the money is but if you are
in the Netherlands where women don't
have to get a stem job in order to have
a decent way of life well then they
won't become doctors as often as they
will go into other forms of of job and
occupation
University of Chicago Economist Stephen
Levitz has quote rather than
interpreting women's lower wages of
failure perhaps it should be seen as a
sign that a higher wage simply isn't as
meaningful and incentive for women as it
is for men
oh how dare we how dare we know in every
inequality of outcome means that America
is terrible and horrible and no good and
very bad which again is why Joe Biden
needs to immediately resign and hand
over his seat to the incredible historic
black sometimes I think they're gonna do
that okay sometimes I think they're
queuing up I guess you don't know as
much about American politics it just
shocks me that that guy is your
president yeah I mean I can't say our
prime minister is much better but he Joe
Biden really is a failure of a man I
think that Michelle Obama they're gonna
make a president someday or try I could
see that yeah I could see that and who
is his vice president that will solve
all of our problems even though by the
way again they can't even Define man and
woman if you ask them what is a man you
know what's so funny about that like
what what what has she achieved to
become president but if you say that
that's misogynistic
I think she wants you some fancy school
that people would argue that Trump trump
doesn't deserve to be president even
though Trump has literally built an
Empire but then they will say yeah
Michelle Obama should be president why
what is a woman they literally have no
definition of these names the easiest
way to solve the gender gap is to Simply
have people stop identifying as a member
of gender at all because gender is
irrelevant boom no genders no pay Gap
incredible we solved it guys it was that
easy
I hope you enjoyed that wow Ben based as
always
um what do you think do you think
was I just so just I just played
volleyball in England and I've just been
horrible discrimination what do you
think
I've just had I've just should I get my
reparations and my like um
my reparations from who the big bad men
yes the men why would you want their
money they're the big bad oh yeah we
should start you're right saying no to
all these government handouts because we
refuse to take money from men yes with
so much better we can do it by ourselves
we'll only have our own businesses
that's it that's it that's it but guys
let me know what you think in the
comments also who are your top five
conservatives of all time uh because I
put my top five on Twitter which you
should follow pearly things with the z
um and people were very triggered so I
was like dang I didn't know this is that
controversial
um tell them
oh I would say tell them where to find
you but we we haven't even put the
videos up yet on your Channel
description
um
say to the people
[Laughter]
I don't really have many words after
after watching that the pay Gap is
yeah like like he said it's a load of
crap now we're super discriminated us
then just send us super chats as like uh
a super thanks for our discrimination
thank you guys like the video on your
way out we'll talk to you next time